[Applaus]
es ist der große auftritt den olaf
scholz beim weltwirtschaftsforum in
davos sucht die augen sind auf ihn
gerichtet welche ziele verfolgt der
deutsche kanzler in der ukraine politik
scholz bleibt bei seiner seit wochen
wiederholten von
putin dorf seinen krieg nicht gewinnen
verbündete formulieren an dass die
ukraine muss kann wird den krieg
gewinnen
die worte gewinn und ukraine hat es noch
nie in einem atemzug genannt er führt
die debatte um das kriegsziel wie er die
debatte um waffenlieferungen geführt hat
defensiv dabei drängt sich die frage
immer mehr auf aber sind die deutschen
kriegsziele das war ein komisches wort
weil deutschland nicht direkt im krieg
teilnimmt aber auch ein mittelbares
militärisches engagement wie
waffenlieferung müsst ihr einen
politischen ziel dienen und das ist doch
so in den letzten wochen eine lehrstelle
in der deutschen politik dass um
klarheit darüber besteht was denn
eigentlich dass der angestrebte ausgang
des konfliktes aus der deutschen sicht
ist 19
regierungserklärung des kanzlers
russland auf diesen krieg nicht gewinnen
die ukraine muss bestehen unklar was
scholz mit bestehen meint in den grenzen
vor der annexion der grimm 2014 in den
grenzen vor dem russischen angriffskrieg
oder in den grenzen die am kriegsende
festgelegt werden ich kann es nur
versuchen zu interpretieren es ist eine
gewisse methode in der politik von olaf
scholz viele hintertürchen offen zu
lassen viele interpretationsspielräume
zuzulassen und dann später zu sagen ja
genau das was dann eingetreten ist habe
er immer schon gesagt ich bedauere das
sehr denn die bundesrepublik deutschland
ist ein land das eigentlich beitragen
müsste zur klarheit es trägt aber im
augenblick mehr zur unklarheit bei
unklarheit die auch russland
interpretationsspielraum bietet scholz
wenig dass die ukraine gewinnt titelt
eine russische nachrichtenseite auch in
der union gibt es diese deutschen in der
koalition uneinigkeit ob die offene
flanke vom kanzler geschlossen werden
muss ich verstehe das die union da
reingeht angesichts der 16 jahre
kanzlerschaft von angela merkel die sich
weder um die ukraine noch um die
bundeswehr gekümmert hat ist das
bedauerlich ich bin immer eine freundin
davon dass man keinen
interpretationsspielraum lässt und ich
hoffe dass dieser spielraum weit
geschlossen wird kannst du schulz hat
eine klare aber auch abwägen der linie
und deshalb ist diese linie
manchmal nicht so
freieres marktschreierisch wie die von
anderen aber ich glaube gerade deshalb
genießt er großes vertrauen nicht nur in
deutschland sondern auch in europa in
umfragen allerdings schwindet das
vertrauen in den kanzler in den
osteuropäischen eu-staaten wächst das
misstrauen
die premierministerin von estland etwa
fordert den militärischen sieg der
ukraine die enttäuschung über die
deutsche defensivhaltung ist im baltikum
unverhohlen es tropft das vertrauen in
deutschland ist nahezu bei null
angekommen
wo steht der kanzler die die chance
jetzt erklären erklären auch warum er
nicht wie andere vom sieg der ukraine
spricht die müssen einfach dann sagen
was sie mit gewinnen ausdrücken wollen
wenn sie damit sagen wollen dass der
russische angriff zurückgeschlagen
werden soll und dass der kampf um die
neu besetzten gebiete gewonnen werden
muss dann haben sie recht wenn sie damit
aber nahe legen wollen dass die ukraine
einschließlich der krim alles
militärisch zurück erobern sollte dann
haben sie eine sehr hypothetische
auffassung von dem was militärisch
möglich ist
der kanzler könnte seine position auf
großer bühne erklären er tut es nicht
dass eine militärische zurückeroberung
der besetzten gebiete ausserhalb des
möglichen liegt diese position hat
scholz offenbar in den lehrstellen
seiner formeln versteckt